all right diamond
hi mark welcome back thank you great to
see you again
it's always good to see me i think
you're always modest well i
i enjoy myself so i had a nice talk last
time short one but a nice one what
what do you think it is about your about
the street life that
that took you down that path i mean like
so many young girls are into it and they
just
very few of the very few if any of them
are getting anywhere in life
yet it's it's like they they're right
about that and you're right about you
know
is this if you don't take your money or
take what you know and use it um
quick and fast i would say like that um
and get out get what you got to get and
then go
like accomplish whatever you need to
accomplish whatever goal you're trying
to get
and go get out of it because you know
they say this fast money
people don't respect like if you had a
job doing
your job um you would save your money
more because you work hard for it you
know
because everybody comes so easy and so
fast
we waste it so we don't think about the
future when especially when you're that
young when you're like
your teens out here or your early 20s
you know all you see is
the cliche you see what um i i would say
um
the rappers the tv you know you're
trying to keep up with them and
lord knows you can't you know because
first of all you got this pimp on the
side of here
you got your family over here and you
really really don't want
nobody know what you're doing because
you're not even in the area you live in
doing it so and it seems like you know
everybody
around you including yourself is doing
something devious
oh my god nobody's devious is part of
the game
it is the game everybody is a major part
of it it's all
about scamming everybody it's all about
illusion it's a it's one big scam
that's what it is because my job is not
to do it
you know my job is to get money out of
you the best way i can
without doing little of nothing you know
all i have to do is suit up and show up
and they post a follow
so i don't know but i haven't had too
many problems with my job description
um i get a few bumps in the road because
i deal with [ __ ] that
ain't [ __ ] so that makes me become uh
part of that a [ __ ] crew
you know so have you ever worked with a
pimp negative
no for what why would i need to give my
money to somebody else
okay i know how to manage my money just
right okay
now you're one of nine siblings yes i am
i'm the oldest
floor oh floor okay uh did any of your
siblings get into the streetlight
no no and i wanted to judge them too
all my sisters are squares you know
others and
go to school go to college or they live
a normal life you know so
they're getting drunk and doing normal
[ __ ] when you guys get together do they
oh we'll get together as a blast they
laugh and roll their eyes oh my god no
roll their eyes but i am loved very much
so
i'm the big sister you know they love
and respect me to the fullest
so you know they like my pocket too they
like to ask to call me that's money
sometimes too
you know like it grows on trees or
something but anyhow but
what do you think it was about your
genetic makeup or your
environment or what something about took
you down this path instead of well we
discussed that before
you know um i was intrigued by the the
look
you know without the like on the outside
you know the dress up the makeup
you know the fantasy look that was
intrigued by that at 13 you know you're
easily to be influenced by a lot of
things you know and
coming from nothing to wanting something
and this looks like oh my god look
they're pretty dressed up
um you know that was my that's what got
my attention
basically the look you know i had no
clue what was i was stored for
whatsoever but yeah but anyways
but you didn't have a whole lot of other
alternatives i mean the
glamour to you was the streets rather
than maybe going to an expensive
shopping area and working in a store or
doing something well i didn't feel the
need to have to work so hard
in a store when i was going to make this
amount of money
these amount of minutes with these
amount of seconds
uh compared to the store every two weeks
pay yeah
i mean what the [ __ ] does that sound
like that sounds didn't sound too good
to me at the time
the fast money becomes too tempting man
i mean [ __ ]
money's tipped it anyways it's the root
of all evil
it's an interesting career because your
your people's skills must get
really developed quickly right because
you have to get along it depends
get along really really well and have
intimate relationships with all kinds of
strengths
i do not intimate [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
let me put this cigarette out mark the
floor
intimate that's funny you have to get
along with everybody
well of course you got to have swag and
people skills in order
to you know it's like in a store you
know don't be working around that cash
register if you ain't gonna be uh
smiling you know on the other side
were there were there nights where you
just didn't want to do it didn't we're
in the mood and you have to
tolerate these i'm never in the mood
never none of the nights
you're never in the mood i'm always in
the movie the one thing and that's the
dollars
so you know i think big you know i like
everything i got champagne taste
with peanut butter money so i'm always
thinking big i always want something
better
i got too many damn habits that are very
expensive
that must be taken care of has your has
your
view of men changed over the years
you've been doing this a long time well
you know mentor man you know
me and feed me clothes me provide for me
so you know
without them hey i wouldn't be able to
be lit i wouldn't be able to you know
survive today
pay bills to pay rent you know they they
are my they are my i will say uh how you
say it
i guess i'm like co-worker uh i'll leave
my boss
[ __ ] they might they pay me my pay
that's how i'll put we'll put that
they pay me and they pay me good you
know
and i'm good as much as i can be and
you love men you hate men you you you
tolerate them i love men
i love me and what they do for me i love
what they do for me
you know they do a lot of things for me
that i need [ __ ] your kids
my kids do you have kids i got five kids
on my grandma
really yeah wow
and uh you raise your kids i can't
remember no i didn't raise my children
my mother raised my children for me
i only raised my children to do um
financial
yeah yeah you know i didn't get to
option raise my kids because
my my past my life in my life the path i
took in my life um
didn't allow me to um have kids in my in
my environment
my environment is not for no kids you
know my environment is not for anybody
that doesn't have a strong stomach
period you know if you ain't got guts
and
if you i mean my vibration is not safe
for a lot of people
that doesn't know what they're doing i
can't explain the [ __ ] mark he's hard to
explain you ask me [ __ ] that i can't
explain but
i i would try to play the best way i can
but uh
[ __ ] i was just my environment and i'm
part of my environment
and i don't have to be in my environment
i could choose to do other things about
you just not choose to
you know because i'm not dumb or stupid
you know i'm a little goofy sometimes
but other than that you know i can
choose to get out of this lifestyle if i
want to
it's not easy i'm not gonna say that
it's not easy at all you just you know
retiring
from this year you know because you go
from making this to trying to make that
and the struggle is like with me it's
the struggle i don't like to struggle
you know
because i'm a worrywort so struggling
for me is like
i ain't gonna better do it you know
because it it makes pressure you know
and it causes me to you know do things
that i know i shouldn't be doing
you know so i don't like to struggle so
i don't think i'll be able to do night
of her job
i would like to own my own business one
day you know and i do have a lot of
skills in a lot of areas you know as far
as um schooling you know
i'm not stupid i didn't finish school
but i stopped there either
so i don't know can you
i mean if you're asking something
interesting if you had something
if you had your life to live all over
again would
you wouldn't for what it might turn out
real but my try worse than it already is
no regret so you have no regrets no
regrets no not yet
saying some of these [ __ ] i'll be
picking i'll be regretting
but besides that i don't got no regrets
my life is what it is and i don't cry
about spoiled milk and i don't worry
about
the word of [ __ ] i couldn't why and why
not i just go with the flow mark because
hey i'm just here
i'm just here doing what i have to do to
survive to eat sleep and [ __ ]
and guess what i do what i gotta do by
all means necessary you're one of the i
think you're the only
woman that works the streets who
referred to being raped as
that's part of the job it's a it is part
of a job you jumping out of cars and
[ __ ] you don't know
you you better be expected you better
expect anything to happen
you know hey [ __ ] no when you when
you're putting people that don't know
what the streets are at risk of being
raped
so you put your self at risk you work in
the street i mean
you put yourself a race for the streets
for all kinds of [ __ ] you just get
subjects all kind of [ __ ]
to happen to you i mean but that's your
choice you make if you want to it's
just the job that you want i was there
last night i see these girls wearing
these crazy short dresses and high heels
and they're
dressing like that because see i'm not
gonna show off all my shields like get
free nuts but they're jumping into cars
with strangers that they've never met
before they don't know who this guy is
yeah jeffrey dahmer
yeah absolutely john wayne casey is
driving there yeah
[Music]
no i'm just kidding so uh
where where does your life go from here
how do i know where my life goes from
here mark you think you could do this
psyche i relate to cleo look out away
you can't do this forever i don't know
if she
[ __ ] i hope i don't have to i will hope
someday somebody will come and sue me
off my pre-feed
and take care of you yes i need someone
to take care of my back be hurting
sometimes
you demand her up your feet i need a man
to rub everything baby
especially my pockets especially my
pockets
because they hurt like a [ __ ]
right now coronavirus is kicking my ass
and everybody around me
all right you've been in love before
yeah
i'm in love now i don't want to talk
about that
cause he gets on my [ __ ] nerve too i
don't talk about no [ __ ]
i swear i don't [ __ ] let's go back to me
what's your favorite quality about
yourself personality trait
oh [ __ ] oh i have so many
let me think my favorite you like
yourself i love myself
[ __ ] i'm good to me you know it took me
a long time to learn how to be good to
me
so i didn't learn how to be good to me
overnight you know
so today as we speak today oh yeah
it came nothing about me discouraged me
from doing what i need to do because i
have faith in me and all i do
and i will succeed at whatever i do
because that's the plan
okay since we're going to talk about
mark i'm done with this interview
okay diamond thank you very much you
love it
any time thank you pleasure's all mine
you